ce n'est pas dans l'intérêt du
gouvernement de bloquer des sites cette
transaction nous perdons trop de nos
entreprises nous perdons trop nos sièges
sociaux c'est une journée triste pour le
québec
725 une sensation qui a été souhaité par
le conseil d'administration de rona la
ministre de l'économie qui sans
expérience le dit qu'elle a obtenu des
garanties maire roland et napoléon sont
maintenant appliquer et je rappelle que
pour un roannais de couche-tard iris et
gilles recep taux beaucoup de réactions
à cette transaction annoncée hier le
gouvernement couillard aurait-il dû
aurait-il pu en faire plus pour empêcher
krona soit vendu aloses daniel tâche à
michel bonsoir tâche à tous les partis
d'opposition à droite comme à gauche qui
ont dénoncé cette vente ont aussi accusé
le gouvernement de ne pas avoir fait
assez pour protéger donc cette
entreprise québécoise est ce que le
gouvernement se soucie assez de garder
les sièges sociaux au québec c'est pas
la responsabilité du gouvernement de
dire une entreprise privée comme celle
là comme rona quoi faire dans ce cas ci
c'est pas un bien national c'est pas une
entreprise qui fabrique des choses
secret où quelque chose extrêmement
important on pourrait dire c'est une
quincaillerie soyons honnêtes écouter
quand métro exprimé trop acheté a été et
l'aube en ontario est ce que le
gouvernement ontarien a dit oh mon dieu
on achète nos épiceries du québec ça
veut dire ni québécois je pense vraiment
c'est une exagération et de plus on sait
qu'ils vont garder la marque de commerce
au québec qui vont garder les dirigeants
québécois ça va pas changer le style de
rona simplement que le fait que c'est
acheté par autre parole aux kits
américains sont tout de même des profits
qu'ils étaient faits au québec qui s'en
vont maintenant aux états-unis michelle
ça crée aussi une certaine instabilité
pour les fournisseurs
une inquiétude aussi au sujet des
emplois ici
pour les franchisés le gouvernement
aurait pu faire plus au point où j'en
étais céline je pense qu'il est un peu
trop tard pour agir ce que je trouve
plus est plus inquiétant c'est que les
gouvernements donnent l'impression qu'à
aucun moment il ya senti qui était de
son devoir d'intervenir parce que
écouter ces bonnes surprises
en 2012 la hausse avait essayé d'acheter
de façon hostile c'est vrai acheter au
nord cette fois ci il y à gréement du
conseil d'adminstration accord du
conseil d'administration de la caisse de
dépôt c'est pas une opération seul mais
c'était tellement prévisible et là
encore plus inquiétant le gouvernement
nous écoute et il va en avoir d'autres
et de toute évidence n'interviendra pas
davantage alors sur le coup il était
trop tard mais il n'est pas trop tard
pour prévenir alors daniel est ce qu'on
doit s que le gouvernement doit réserver
les gestes d'éclat pour bloquer une
transaction uniquement quand il s'agit
d'un secteur stratégique
quand il s'agit quand il s'agit ici ce
plusieurs experts de 2-2-2 siège social
stratégique pour des raisons
stratégiques pour des raisons
identitaires le gouvernement couillard
devrait profiter de cette vente de rona
est-ce qu'il devra l'empêcher non est-ce
qu'il devrait s'en mêler non selon moi
mais il devrait il devra en profiter
pour comme si michel établir des balises
et 10 rebonds au now comprend ce sont
les lois du marché
les gens de rooney voulait vendre à tout
prix ça me semble évident sauf que il y
aura tel et tel domaine où ce n'est ses
touches pas c'est inaccessible
on se bat bec et ongles pour l'empêcher
pour des raisons stratégiques des
raisons identitaires je pense à la
banque nationale évidemment voudrait-on
la laisser partir à toronto
je conviens a mentionné cgi il ya de ces
fleurons qui font partie de l'âme du
québec et qu'on ne peut pas laisser
aller est ce que est ce que c'est le bon
moment d'établir ces balises l'oeil que
ce soit très clair
plusieurs le pensent tasha je vous vois
réagir mais simplement que je pense que
chaque fois que le gouvernement ait un
gr pour des raisons stratégiques on a vu
ça avec protège cooperation au canada
mais ça se passe pas seulement au québec
un pur délice entreprises canadiennes
qui sont rachetés aussi ça se passe au
canada on a vu ça et il arrive ce qui
passait les actions de potash en jeu
et le prix du potache lui même a baissé
et la valeur de la compagnie abc ensuite
il aurait pu vendre la compagnie à un
grand profit pour les actionnaires ils
n'ont pas permis alors que quelques fois
même quand c'est quelque chose qui est
stratégiquement on pourrait dire une
ressource stratégique c'est une mauvaise
décision du gouvernement de simplement
dire non on va pas le faire on a vu ça
avec des compagnies chinoises où le
gouvernement a dit oui là il ya une
question de sécurité nationale on va pas
permettre la vente de certains compagnie
a laissé prix entreprise étatique
chinoise messieurs harper avait fait ça
alors il ya des moments mais dans ce que
si je pense vraiment une exagération
monsieur péladeau saisi n'importe quoi
pour qu'on oublie ses problèmes à lui et
qu on se divertit avec cette situation
là
michel rey justement qu'est ce que vous
avez pensé du ton des échanges parce que
l'opposition a été assez à beaucourt et
oui le oui je comprends que le policier
a réagi de cette façon là parce que
écoutez c'est enrageant les premières
réactions du gouvernement s'était
pratiquement de nous dire que c'est une
bonne nouvelle
je comprends que c'est pas une
entreprise stratégique mais c'est
certainement une entreprise structurants
antalya y en a 500 déroulera au québec
c'est des dizaines de milliers d'emplois
alors ça pas besoin d'être
l'aéronautique le pour être structurant
maintenant monsieur péladeau honnêtement
je pense que il savait aussi bien tout
le monde qui a pas moyen de remettre la
dalle la pâte dentifrice dans le tube
mais l'occasion était belle pour mettre
la nouvelle super ministre de l'économie
sur la sellette et franchement madame
anglade un moment qu'ils sont entrés par
ce que nous dit que c'est une bonne
affaire ça a pris 24 heures avant ce
coup y'a pour dire écoutez c'est quand
même un peu préoccupant ce soir là mais
celui qui a mieux réagi je pense c'est
françois legault qui a écouté les loyers
trop tard mais il ya des stratégies ça
existe dans tous les pays du monde qu'on
élabore des stratégies pour garder nos
sièges sociaux et il n'y a aucune raison
que québec fasse pas la même chose
didot là il ya quand même une
vulnérabilité qui l'a qu'il présenta se
demandent quelle sera la prochaine
entreprises et pas seulement le dollar
et le contexte d'aujourd'hui mais moi ce
qui m'étonne un peu et tout que je
comprends pas très bien dans les
réactions de monsieur péladeau et le
gaucher que 188 quand le canada a signé
un traité de libre-échange avec les
états-unis a au québec on a applaudi à
tout rompre bernard landry en tête les
plusieurs souverainistes monsieur paris
jouait toujours dit que québec
indépendant fera partie de tous ces
grands traités de libre échange ue ce
traité n'a eu l'année n'a par la suite
gouvernement a pronostiqué une bonne
douzaine il y en a deux très gros avec
l'union européenne et le partenariat
transpacifique qui en attente de
ratification
bref on est dans un contexte très large
de libre échange où tout circule
beaucoup plus librement
est ce que le québec de monsieur
péladeau de monsieur de gauche pose la
question je n'ai pas la réponse serait
le québec très protectionniste et 6 dvg
un gouvernement
ah je connais pas la réponse ça arrive
des deux bords des frontières ou les
pays des entreprises icône et qu'on
pourrait dire achète les entreprises de
l'autre et ça arrive et je pense pas
qu'il faut il faut être tellement déçu
je pense est un succès le fait que
benoît est attrayant c'est un succès
cette entreprise là et ça va demeurer un
succès lowe's a aucun intérêt de
détruire la marque de commerce comme on
a alors pourquoi il le ferait mais si on
aurait très forte rationalisation il n'y
arrivera pas toutes ces petites
quincaillerie chaque fois il ya ce genre
de prise de contrôle
il ya une rationalisation qui soit ya
des emplois qui sont perdus il ya des
des établissements qui disparaît c'est
inévitable guerrier peter may est
évident que les décisions stratégiques
vont être prises aux états unis
maintenant c'est pas vous servez le
convoi décider quelles vont être les
orientations de la chaîne et il ya des
fournisseurs qui peuvent être avantagé
actuellement parce que le prix du dollar
et le cours du dollar est bas mais ça ne
durera pas éternellement
alors je pense que c'est une mauvaise
nouvelle pour l'économie québécoise
bon alors là dessus on va se tourner
vers le fédéral maintenant la semaine
prochaine on va souligner les 100 jours
les 100 premiers jours du gouvernement
de justin trudeau s'il ya une chose qui
a changé déjà et c'est assez clair c'est
le ton ça se voit entre autres dans les
entrevues qu'a qu'accorde le premier
ministre hugo
j'aimerais d'ailleurs qu'on regarde deux
courts extraits en décembre patrice roy
effet une entrevue avec justin trudeau
il y avait il s'était promené dans le
métro justin trudeau avait pu parler à
des gens et ailleurs d'ailleurs et a
subi si dimanche dernier elle aussi une
émission spéciale où justin trudeau a
été questionné directement par dix
canadiens alors on regarde les str
extrait on vient tout cet aprem ensemble
je m'appelle qui intervenant social est
ce que tu as des amis qui savent pas
seulement acheter la maryse ces jours ci
oui en effet
alors cette jeune femme si jeune
autochtone elle avait deux personnes
dans sa famille je vois sa cousine et sa
tante qui ont disparu dont elle en a
parlé avec le premier ministre en lui
demandant des questions sur le l'enquêté
et c'est donc un premier ministre qui
souhaite montrer qu'il est à l'écouté
des canadiens qu'il est accessible alors
tasha vous avez dit déjà que c'était un
exercice superficielle avait parlé de
politique spectacle
pourquoi qu'est ce qui vous a déplu ça
va des plus le fait qu' on fait tant de
spectacles j'irai aussitôt écoute ses
100 jours comme monsieur trudeau est là
si on avait fait cet exercice dans six
mois ou un an pour faire un type de
vérification faite sur ces
accomplissements ou prendre le pouls de
la population pour qu ils soient en
contact avec les gens je pense qu'ils
auraient eu du mérite là dedans mais le
problème que j'ai c'est que il parle
beaucoup aux joueurs wii c'est une force
mais s'il le fait trop je trouve ça
devient une certaine faiblesse parce que
les gens se posent le 1er mars qui va
passer à l'action et deuxièmement c'est
presque une distraction ça implique t
gouverner c'est parler cette époque
parler oui il faut parler aux faux
communiqué mais cette ouverture
constante c'est comme gouverneur télé
réalité je trouve ça devient un peu trop
mais pendant ce temps là je dis à ces
mini ce travail etc
avant on avait un premier ministre
faisait de la politique sur son temps
libre il écrivait des livres sur le rock
ici je me souviens bien
est-ce que je peux le gouvernement
continue de faire son travail mais
monsieur j'ai pas été un peu trop fermé
c'est ça le problème
il était vu et c'est vrai il avait son
gouvernement était trophée remis envers
la population ils n'avaient pas la
communication et avec les médias et avec
la bureaucratie et avec les gens
ordinaires je dirais alors ces deux
réactions je comprends les gens veulent
parler aux prémices sont contents qu'il
soit aussi ouvert mais comme j'ai dit ça
peut aller aussi un peu trop loin
michel on parle beaucoup du temps donc
de l'image au delà de ça quand même 100
jours trois mois et des choses qui ont
été faites il ya des choses qui ont été
faites mais je sur le temps on peut pas
à la fois reproché aux politiciens
d'être déconnectée parce que leur dire à
leur reprocher de parler directement aux
électeurs et il ya un risque pour les
prix mais moi je peux très friands de ce
genre de spectacle là mais vous savez
quand on voit un premier ministre jouer
au chat et à la souris avec un
journaliste professionnel on se dit bon
ça fait partie du jeu mais quand vous
avez devant vous une jeune femme lakic
qui vous expliquent qu est pas capable
de joindre les deux bouts halle et que
vous répondez par les infrastructures
ça paraît très mal et c'est un risque
les policiers c'est dangereux
souvenez-vous brian mulroney la petite
madame sur la colline parlementaire
qu'il l'avait apostrophé sur les
passions la socam assuma drones et il
servirait de base s'apprêtent elles en
sont terminés cette journée là si je me
souviens bien
non moi je pense est-ce que ce cri a pas
mal mais j'étais pour l'ailé saint jo
mais ont regardé
moi moi j'écoute et je suis d'accord
aussi pour le temps et ça fait du bien
ça change un peu varié entre le
gouvernement harper mais ça fait
toujours du bien changé à tous les
niveaux il n'apprend obama ce sera
différent et c'est bien un ski la métro
a mon avis oui mais je suis convaincu
moi que ce qu'on a vu dimanche dernier
la cible ici ou ce qu'il a fait avec
patrice dans temps des fêtes
donc faisons faire pas mal moins souvent
partir de maintenant parce que c'est
très dangereux parce que c'est risqué
parce que ses conseillers vont le musée
récolte
assez c'est assez on fera des entrevues
quand il y aura des bonnes raisons de le
faire quand on a changé les politiques
gouvernementales
pour l'instant il fait les choses je ne
dirais pas facile mais des choses qui
coûtent rien la parité homme-femme la
commission dans lequel sont des
autochtones et la conférence de paris
changer la direction sur l'environnement
tout ça c'est bien c'est beau sauf que
là maintenant il faut un budget il faut
probablement la semaine prochaine
là enfin la décision sur qu'est ce qu'on
fait en irak
comment vont continuer de supporter
d'appuyer la mission qui se bat contre
l'état islamique
là on arrive dans le concret et c'est là
où on va vraiment voir le vrai justin
trudeau
bon alors je vous redonne la parole ni
chaise sur ces 100 joignent à des choses
qui ont été accomplis selon vous où il
ya des choses d'abord ce qui va toucher
le plus les gens c'est la baisse
d'impôts à partir du afin qui est entrée
en vigueur le 1er janvier
et il y réussit aussi à marquer une
rupture avec avec l'air un peu des
petits gestes qui sont pas aussi
compliqué c'est vrai mais qui sont quand
même significatif par exemple redonner
la parole aux scientifiques rétablir le
questionnaire long relancer aussi le
dialogue à l'intérieur de la fédération
lors des conférences de 1900 là ça a
établi un bien meilleur climat
il est évident que les gros morceaux
daniel le disais c'est vrai la décision
sur l'intervention contre l'état
islamique et le budget là le plus de 500
viella des infrastructures comment on va
s'harmoniser avec les provinces le plan
de lutte contre les
gaz à effet de serre le plus gros s'en
vient mais on peut pas dire que monsieur
trop doux n'a rien fait pendant 100
jours ce serait injuste et l'eau et
l'autre si j'ai tout ce qu'on veut de ce
qu'on a devant lui une opposition et
thomas mulcair me sens un peu un petit
peu pour fatiguer mais peu d intérêt si
apple mordant qu'ils avaient avant et
rona ambrose bon show que se débrouille
bien mais elle est encore en train
d'apprendre le métier alors c'est pas
très menaçant pour le reste il nous
reste peu de temps mais tâche avoue
quand même il a fait des avancées ou pas
oui écoutez monsieur trudeau à faire
certaines avancées sur la question de la
fiscalité sur la question de la requête
sur les femmes autochtones disparues
il a gardé les premières si elle n'est
pas garder d'autres concernant les
réfugiés par exemple et l'horaire dans
lequel ils vont être amenés au canada
mais je pense encore que toute la
question du spectacle c'est comme j'ai
dit c'est pas dangereux et dans un sens
c'est dangereux aussi parce que ça fait
penser que le gouverneur c'est comme
votre ami c'est personnaliser le
gouvernement un point où les gens
seraient prêts à accepter un état puis
hier je pense qu'on dit balsan
gouvernance et c'est là pour moi la
personne monsieur trudeau très
sympathique
alors pour un état qui aiment grandir
c'est une bonne stratégie aussi il faut
réfléchir à ça d'accord mais on a
compris qu'ils n'avaient pas trop aimé
cette cette émission mais j'aurais
préféré qu'ils calent sur un plus long
merci merci beaucoup à vous trois et
dimanche à 11 heures aux coulisses du
pouvoir emmanuelle latraverse entretien
avec le maire de montréal denis coderre